>> Dana: PAUL PELOSI'S
ATTACKER HAS PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
THE JUDGE HELD WITHOUT BAIL.
THE LEGAL IMMIGRANT ASSAULTED
PAUL PELOSI IN HIS OWN HOME WITH
A HAMMER.
CHARGES COULD LAND HIM IN JAIL
BEHIND BARS FOR 50 YEARS.
THE SUSPECT IS DESCRIBED AS
MENTALLY ILL FOR A LONG TIME,
CONSTANTLY PARANOID AND HE
THOUGHT HE WAS.
>> ANYTHING STRANGE ABOUT HIM
PUSH MARK BECOME THE ENTIRE
HOUSEHOLD IS VERY STRANGE.
HE IS BIRDS OF A FEATHER WITH
HIS FAMILY.
THEY ARE JUST, DRUG ABUSERS.
THAT'S WHO GRAVITATES TOWARD.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS SEE IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY THE BLAME
GAME.
>> THE VIOLENT POLITICAL
RHETORIC THAT ESPOUSED BY
REPUBLICAN LEADERS IS INSPIRING
ASKED BY INDIVIDUALS LIKE THIS.
>> IT'S RIGHT WING PROBLEM.
>> TOO MUCH POLITICAL VIOLENCE,
TOO MUCH HATRED.
>> ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> THE FIRST THING ABOUT THE
BREAKING NEWS IS THAT THE
SUSPECT IS BEING HELD WITHOUT
BAIL.
>> Greg: IF THE SUSPECT IS
GETTING THE BOOK THROWN AT THEM,
THAT'S GREAT, BUT IT RAISES THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE VICTIM
WAS SOMEONE ELSE THEN PELOSI,
WOULD THERE BE EXCUSES THEN?
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD'VE DONE
IF IT WAS SOMEONE ELSE, REMAND
HIM TO HIS ANKLE BRACELET.
THIS IS ALL DEFLECTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SUSPECT, HE'S
MENTALLY ILL AND HOMELESS IN THE
LEGAL.
THOSE ARE THREE AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATED BY THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
HOMELESS, LET HIM SLEEP ON THE
STREETS THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT OF SAFETY
AND SECURITY.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T EXIST, THEY
GO AFTER SPEECH.
FUNNY THING IS, IF YOU BELIEVE
SPEECH CAUSES VIOLENCE, THAN
WHAT YOU ADVISE?
DO YOU ADVISE HAVING 370 MILLION
PEOPLE CHANGE THEIR DISCORDS TO
APPEASE A TINY NUMBER DERANGED
PEOPLE?
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT YOU COULD INSTITUTIONALIZE
THE MENTALLY ILL, MAKE IT HARDER
FOR THE HOMELESS TO LIVE ON
STREETS, DEPARTMENT ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
THESE ARE PRACTICAL THINGS.
BUT INSTEAD THEY'RE GOING AFTER
WORDS, OTHER ANCHORS, THOUGH
SOME DESERVE IT.
BUT ANYWAY.
I JOKE.
>> Dana: MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER
WHO RAN FOR GOVERNOR, LET'S HEAR
THAT.
>> WERE IN A PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY IN THE UNITED STATES
AS A WHOLE, CALIFORNIA'S
PARTICULAR HARD-HIT ONE OF THE
FOUR RESIDENTS OF SAN FRANCISCO
SAY THEY HAVE EITHER BEEN A
ASSAULTED OR THREATENED WITH
ASSAULT.
HALF SAY THEY HAVE BEEN A VICTIM
OF THEFT OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS.
WE ARE DEALING WITH PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES, DRUG ADDICTION
EMERGENCY, HUGE CRIME PROBLEM.
>> MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER IS SUCH
AN ASSET THE SYSTEM, LET'S BRING
THEM IN.
>> Greg: A DEMOCRAT!
SPEWING HE'S DONE IT A TON OF
WORK.
SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE TO THE
GOOD JOB OF TALKING TO THE
FAMILY AND THE NEIGHBORS.
I'M BAFFLED AT THE SPEED BY
WHICH DEMOCRATS WERE ABLE TO SAY
HE WAS A MEGAN MAGNA REPUBLICAN.
SUPPOSEDLY HE THOUGHT HE WAS AND
COMMITTED AGAINST HIS OWN
CHILDREN THEY SAY.
HE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
ON THE STREETS AT ALL, HE
SHOULDN'T OF BEEN IN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE HE WAS HERE ILLEGALLY.
WE COULD ALL SAY, POLITICAL
SPEECH IS GONE TOO FAR.
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO SLEEP IN THEIR
HOMES FOR MONTHS AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID NOTHING.
STEVE COATES POLICE CAN'T WALK
CORRECTLY BECAUSE HE WAS SHOT.
AT THAT TIME, IT WAS LIKE, LET'S
ALL AGREE THIS IS A LUNATIC AND
THESE ARE PEOPLE RADICALIZED BY
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT THINGS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT'S WHY CRIME IS SUCH A
CONCERN FOR PEOPLE LIVING IN
PLACES LIKE THIS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO OR WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO THINK AT ANY MOMENT?
THEY CAN LASH OUT AT YOU.
WHEN YOU HAVE HOMELESS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT SOMETHING THAT
IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF REPUBLICANS
HAVE A GOOD ANSWER AND
HOMELESSNESS.
AT LEAST PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
SAY WE WANT ORDER.
I HOPE PELOSI GETS BETTER.
THAT'S A TERRIBLE INJURY TO DO.
I FEEL SORRY FOR HIS FAMILY.
NOBODY SHOULD HAVE THIS HAPPEN
TO THEM.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
CONTINUING TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO SHOW UP BEFORE AND AFTER THAT
HAPPENED EVEN AFTER THE ATTACK
ON BRETT KAVANAUGH, OR THE
ATTEMPTED ATTACK OF JUSTICE
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD ALL REFRAIN
EVERY TIME UNTIL WE GET THE
FACTS.
TO WHAT DID HE PLEAD NOT GUILTY?
IT'S AMAZING TO ME.
HE ADMITTED HE WAS THERE TO TAKE
SPEAKER PELOSI AND ASK HER
QUESTIONS AND IF SHE DID TOLD
THE TRUTH HE WAS GOING TO NEED
COVER.
I'M GLAD HE'S BEING HELD.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE GLAD.
WE CAN POINT OUT THE
SHORTCOMINGS AND HYPOCRISY OF
OUR BELL LAWS, THAT SHOULD BE A
BIG PART OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON WHEN REPUBLICANS
TAKE THE HOUSE, IF THEY TAKE THE
HOUSE.
ONE OF THE WORST THINGS ABOUT
THE LAST TWO WEEKS IN POLITICS
IS THAT WE TRY TO INSTIGATE
PEOPLE TO GO VOTE.
WHEN MY DAD WAS IN MY OFFICE, WE
USED TO SAY WHAT WE WERE FOUR.
GUESS WHAT I'M FOR.
OVER TIME THIS EVOLVED INTO, NOT
ONLY AM NOT FOR THE RIGHT
THINGS, BUT HE'S A TERRIBLE
PERSON.
IN POLITICS WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
YOU GET ELECTED, HOW DO YOU
JUSTIFY WORKING WITH SOMEONE IF
YOU THINK THE PERSON DOES NOT
ONLY WRONG BUT A TERRIBLE HUMAN
BEING?
IT'S HARD TO THEN COME ACROSS
THE AISLE AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
WORK TOGETHER >> Greg: HADDAD
BIDEN LAUGHTER SHE CALLED HIM A
RACIST?
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT ACROSS THE
HALL.
GEORGE H.W. BUSH BECAME
VICE PRESIDENT AFTER HE CALLED
RONALD REAGAN'S POLICIES FOR
VOODOO ECONOMICS.
WE'VE GOT A TONE THIS DOWN.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
>> Dana: HE PLED GUILTY TO
PREMEDITATED ATTEMPTED MURDER,
ATTEMPTED BURGLARY, THREATENING
A FAMILY MEMBER OF A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL.
JESSE WRAP IT UP.
>> WE HAVE A MENTALLY ILL,
ILLEGAL ALIEN, DRUG ADDICT, AND
A NEW DESK, HE CONTRIBUTED,
FELONIES AND HE HASN'T BEEN
DEPORTED.
RIGHT THERE, HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED BACK TO CANADA,
INSTITUTIONALIZED OR LOCKED UP
HERE IN THE U.S.
BUT HE WAS ABLE TO PLAY DUMB
LIKE PREY ON PAUL WITH A HAMMER
BECAUSE OF DEMOCRAT POLICIES.
HIS IDEOLOGY IS ALL OVER THE
MAP.
WE HEARD HE WAS SEND OBAMA
SUPPORTER, A PROGRESSIVE.
THEN YOU LOOK AT HIS ONLINE
MATERIALS AND YOU CAN SEE HE'S
ANTI-SEMITIC.
HE PSYCHOTIC.
HE'S TAKING A LOT OF
PSYCHEDELICS WANDERING AROUND AT
MIDNIGHT WITH HAMMERS BUSTING
INTO PEOPLE'S HOMES TRYING TO
KNEECAP PEOPLE.
NOT A GRANT MASTERMIND.
COME ON.
THEY'RE ACTING LIKE THIS GUY IS
SOME KIND OF JANUARY 6 WHO
PLOTTED THIS LINK FOR DECADES.
THIS GUY JUST, COME ON PAUL,
MULTIMILLION THERE, IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
CRIME WAVE DOESN'T HAVE A
WEAPON.
HIS ALARM IS NOT ON.
COME ON PAUL.
IT'S NOT PAUL'S FAULT THIS GUY
IS RESPONSIBLE.
THEY HAVE TO TAKE CERTAIN
MEASURES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THIS PROPERTY
HAS BEEN VANDALIZED TWICE, HIS
NAPA PLACE HAS BEEN BURGLARIZED.
I HOPE HE FEELS BETTER AND HE
RECOVERS AND HE AND NANCY CAN GO
TO ITALY AND RETIRE ON THE